[Applause]
uh did you guys watch the chapelle
response i did yeah did you watch
chappelle's most recent response to all
this [ __ ] the one to the trans community
right he seems a little tuned up to be
honest with you yeah this is that guy's
swirling who's this dave chappelle
everybody
this story will not go away mark you saw
it yeah so dave chappelle basically came
out and responded to the trans employees
who walked out and i guess he was saying
which i didn't see this to be fair the
media was saying he refused to meet with
the netflix employees he wanted to meet
with him and he was like that's not true
they never asked me sure uh never got to
him i never yeah he was like i'll gladly
meet with you guys but i have a list of
demands you got that yeah all right i
got it that's that's me normally so i
have my patience with it but i also see
where schultz is like how do you not get
it
yeah um schultz studios falling apart
yeah what's going on
[Laughter]
i've never seen the mic like that that's
good it looks like that no no just rest
on your stomach
this is the fattest you've ever been
treated yeah it is i wanted to sit in
that chair you got me sitting in this
thing i'm old yeah we should have
trusted you yeah yeah this chair i don't
know can handle it though because you've
already broken one of these chairs i sat
in that last time the green one or the
pink bunk
i sat in this one yeah oh damn oh [ __ ]
okay well listen
start over
we'll restart if you need to we'll
switch at some point i'll have to piss
eventually he's fine i'm great but uh
chappelle had a list of demands he was
like look i'll meet with the trans
community but i have a list of demands
which is a funny flip uh one of them was
um you will meet at a time and place of
my choosing which i wonder what he would
choose which is hilarious buckies or
something yeah
what would it be that's not like what
does that even mean i think he just felt
like i'm not gonna go get summoned sure
that was i think it was a big respect
thing and i have that too like you don't
[ __ ] tell me that's like i don't care
if you're asking me to do something dave
chappelle's got a little bit of cash on
him and he probably he would probably
want to do it if i was him i'd be like
yo let's do it
at a let's do it in front of a live
audience
so i can [ __ ] own you yeah and i know
like you're not cause one you're one
you're not gonna be a good public
speaker two
your ideas in theory i get what you're
saying but it's like he's more practical
so hopefully embarrass somebody and he's
just so [ __ ] smart that there's
there's a level of it knows how to work
a crowd there's a big enough gap in
intelligence that no if you're right or
wrong you will win it doesn't matter how
wrong does it if you're if the gap is
big enough it's that college debate
right like disprove that like even if
you're like [ __ ] mine's not the
strongest poke holes and the smart
defense attorney the [ __ ] ted's
whatever his name is sandrews or
whatever the [ __ ] surrenders sorrandos i
want to say sandusky and i had to
i had to play last second
fame netflix
hey i'm a [ __ ] emailing me suck my
dick
[Laughter]
ted sarandos is not smart enough to hang
with dave chappelle in a debate so the
netflix employees are not going to be
able to do it this guy's sure
brennan said it well he said his brain
belongs in the smithsonian so if he does
live debate there's no chance that's why
if i was him like let's do it live let's
you know let's do it live like [ __ ]
what's his name bill o'reilly oh yeah
i'll do it live yeah
wait he said he should be in the
smithsonian that's what neil brennan
said you said put dave chappelle's brain
in the smithsonian like it's a [ __ ]
marvel i feel like it would look the
same as every other brand all right
but like do they put brains in the
museum yeah is that a thing like walking
right next to fonzie's jacket
[Laughter]
man that's a good ass point you really
saw through the brain
i just thought it sounded so good i
bought in i was like this guy man yeah
you convinced me of his [ __ ] i was
like
[ __ ] mark's like my brain i'm like
yeah i don't know anymore
um i do think uh netflix last night i
went home uh i like opened up netflix
and the first thing at the top was his
old documentary
so they're like doubling down they're
like dude we're just pushing him we know
it's hot so this is where they just
think you're a transphobe they're like
oh yeah yeah based on your viewing
history you don't like trains so there
were there were two other demands you
remember the second demand mark maybe we
can pull it up yeah i'll pull it up the
second one i think was uh
oh well you have to watch the whole
special yeah you have to watch the whole
switch no watch the whole special in his
entirety thank you and the third one you
have to admit hannah gatsby isn't funny
which is again why he's the best at what
he does because to end it like that is
perfect
yeah i do you take it
yeah i took it as like
listen i'm serious but this like this is
like the sugar that makes the medicine
go down a little bit yes
it was clearly a shot at that and it was
a shot at hannah because i think she i'm
sure she had a partially stunted world
view or something like that and like uh
she went at him pretty hard sure so he
was just like one little bang there you
go so i got you and it ends everything
on a nice funny note and yeah the sugar
that makes the medicine go down i
thought what do you think overall of the
whole thing
i said my thoughts in the group text but
i'll say them again here
i don't know i i do think i get but it
is like i do think
both sides have a point to an extent
it's like he has spent what three
specials now
yeah harping on the same topic and i'm
like i i also as a comedian and a huge
fan of him i'm like i want to see i do i
want to see this put to rest yeah i want
to see something else like i want to see
the five year gap and then he comes back
with [ __ ] heat yeah this is one of
the best storytellers he's released like
what like four specials in like four or
whatever it is three years or whatever
it is it's like i would like to see
something else but i do get that it's
like that's a big part of his life
they're coming down publicly they're
dragging him publicly and he's like yeah
this is what i do i have a public forum
to discuss this so i'm going to yeah i
think it's like six specials in four
years something crazy
yeah that's insane uh mark what do you
think yeah i mean it's sort of the same
thing where i'm like okay i like that
he's
trying to put this to rest and like
ideally he moves on i i also trust that
he's savvy enough to know what he's
doing i agree where i'm like i view it
from my perspective it's like okay like
he's sort of
you know upset that his thing is getting
pulled out of film festivals but it's
also getting screened at like literally
arenas sure so i'm like if you look at
like the bare bones of it it seems
like it's kind of uh like a
dramatization of what's going on yeah
it's marketing at the end yeah it's not
it's
his tide's going up but that's exactly
my point feels like marketing which is
fine because that's what he's supposed
to do is market his [ __ ] sure so as like
a fan i get wrapped up in the marketing
where i'm like oh yeah this is great
let's [ __ ] go but then if you step
away i'm sort of like all right i can
it's i don't millionaire's complaining
about there's stuff like that like yeah
you're like 100 million taken from me
this is taken from me it's like you're
what you have literally you can do and
you can make anything you want and
you'll make millions of dollars yeah but
i'm also a fan of dave so i'm like
[ __ ] yeah i thought this was when you
were talking about what was me is tough
i'm like i get it like but here's the
thing when you talk about how smart
chappelle is whether the saying makes it
in the sense or not put in the
smithsonian in his brain i think he
started using his brain to
negotiate and market and make money of
course in the past i thought the um the
netflix give me the rights to my show
back to mtv and viacom yeah was a
brilliant like that's the only way you
can win in that negotiation is you get
the people completely on your she's
doing that again and he's doing it again
with i have this documentary that nobody
wants me to air and no i guarantee you
every network will take dave chappelle's
thing sure but in the meantime it's
forbidden hey guys let's sell tickets to
an arena tour he's gonna make 10 million
dollars off that tour easy just filming
a movie and then coming out and saying
some [ __ ] and then he's gonna get it to
netflix and then he's gonna make another
however many million dollars it's so
it's very small [ __ ] smart dude i was
impressed just off rip with the way he
did the whole thing nobody can package
anything like chappelle sure it's
incredible that was my thought this is
the greatest marketing i've i've ever
seen one person do for two different
projects six months apart it's [ __ ]
unreal yeah that's insane what's up guys
we're gonna take a break from this
exclusive patreon clip to tell you guys
about lucy look we're all adults here
and sometimes people use nicotine some
people use it to relax some people use
it to focus some people just want to
unwind after a long day well if you do
use nicotine you need to know about lucy
because it is a company created to help
you find a cleaner option and feel
better about the way you consume your
nicotine the latest product is a slim
nicotine pouch which which contains pure
synthetic nicotine but provides the same
satisfaction nicotine users expect with
no tobacco at all the slim pouches are
the newest technology for synthesizing
pure nicotine in the lab no tobacco all
of the nicotine satisfaction they come
in three strengths four eight and 12
milligrams and they have exclusive
delicious flavors spearmint mango cool
cider
look again i'm not gonna use nicotine
but i know a lot of people who do and
they're sitting there crushing
cigarettes or god knows what with god
knows what stuff in it just use a
cleaner alternative this is
synthetically made it's pure it's a
cleaner alternative to nicotine so in
2021 do not compromise when you're
choosing your nicotine products go with
the newest tobacco-free options from
lucy and if you go go to lucy.co and use
our promo code flagrant to get 20 off
your order of lucy slim pouches or any
other lucy products again that is lucy
l-u-c-y dot c-o and use the promo code
flagrant to get 20 off your order
now i have to read this verbatim i have
to read this disclaimer
this product contains non-tobacco
nicotine nicotine is an addictive
chemical
but if you're gonna chew nicotine if
you're gonna use nicotine use lucy now
let's get back to the show have you ever
seen a lot have you ever seen a
lunchable until fifth grade no my mom
never bought them dude lunchables are
such trash
that's a trash it is i'll walk out of
here right now buddy there's not a
single good lunchable in history i never
[ __ ] maybe crazy maybe lunchable
technology has advanced
but when it was cheese and crackers and
[ __ ] bologna what's wrong with you
get my dick yeah slide a capri sun in
there that's clean there's way better
options that's not even clean living
buddy that's trash for trash yeah none
of that is good yeah and you'll agree
dessert is not a mini crunch bar you
know what i mean well i'm a big fan of
the crunch bars that is not the yeah
mini crunch bar eat my dick i'm telling
you none of that is good baloney and
bread is poor still better than baloney
and a cracker it just is get an actual
bologna sandwich he's got his kids got
points are you paying more for the lunch
and you're putting together like an
[ __ ]
yeah you do nothing no mama's gone
making his lunch that's what they're
doing in the fancy restaurants that's
true
they were ahead of their time the pizza
was [ __ ] pizza i used to pretend i used
to convince myself it was good it's nuts
it was cold sauce cold frozen cheese
yeah what were we doing you're eating
nothing what's a good lunchable miles
i was gonna say the pizza
no way this guy's garbage garbage it had
a you just novel for a second i just
like yeah garbage i like taking the
pizza sauce and just getting the hole in
it and just slurping wow
yeah
that is [ __ ] i
[Laughter]
he looks like a clerk at
see bucky his first contribution to the
polish i like to slurp the tomato sauce
i love the honesty though that's
fantastic i like a cold can of spaghetti
dude
i took a mega bus one time and it's like
you know when you like sit down you're
looking for like you're trying you're
doing the math and as you walk back
you're like oh i could sit here and that
you know yeah so hoping nobody says next
hope and nobody sits and he's like if
you see like somebody like do i hedge my
bets and sit with them or like what do
you do so i find it and i see uh this
tiny little asian girl and i'm like
perfect
she's not gonna be like fall it's not
like a big it's not like i'm sitting
next to foley they're falling into my
seat tiny little girl she has headphones
in mine in her own business i go okay i
sit there so i sit down next to her do
we pull out of the parking lot she pulls
out like 40 [ __ ] ketchup packets oh
really wait justin
what the [ __ ] yeah
just sucking packing that's my dream
crackers and stuff
it was a lot of condiments and i was
like so talk to her what's the deal
that's the crazy [ __ ] i've ever heard of
in my life it was nuts i had another guy
took his shirt off just right next to me
[ __ ] you didn't ask to put it on a
dude a guy with the confidence to take
his shirt off it's not like he's not
like well what if somebody asked me to
put it back on he's living in his own
reality that's true he's that's an
invitation to somebody tell me to put my
[ __ ] shirt on when did you stop
taking the mega bus as soon as i could i
was amtrak yeah oh am tr i still don't i
mean amtrak's one thing i mean amtrak's
like 400 amtrak up until dc from new
york to dc is class and then the second
you go south the long balls are tough
bruh i saw a guy swear to god like three
years ago maybe get on an amtrak and
pull out a [ __ ] sony disc man
remember the 1990s cd player that's got
10 seconds anti-skip yeah yeah that [ __ ]
duct tape hard as [ __ ] and i was like
this is a guy i got to be nice to
because he will kill me for meth money
yeah the buses are something else yeah i
haven't taken a bus in years years years
now you flip it there's another driver
yeah does anybody in here still own any
dvds
i don't that's because i moved a bunch
but i don't yeah
i never purchased it i don't think he'd
ever participated never purchased a dvd
i don't think so miles did you maybe
marcus 27 yo he's 18 years younger than
he's 25 i'm 27. he's 25. oh mark is 20
years younger than that
yeah he looks old as [ __ ] right now
[Laughter]
mark is 25 20 years younger than you
that's crazy i know because he looks old
as [ __ ]
miles is 27.
yeah where are you from miles sarasota
florida they're both florida boys they
went to college together miles is here
because mark
put him on very early with the youtube
thing before it was netflix and i'll
start doing graphics and for netflix he
[ __ ] killed himself
yeah okay well that was a [ __ ] great
job thank you wow that was fantastic did
all the graphics every graphic you see
that's miles holy [ __ ] yeah fantastic
every word you read
that's android
no these guys [ __ ] killed it and now
they're here and we're happy to have
them but that i judge the [ __ ] out of
the lunchables thing man yeah my dad
still has dvds
yeah that's a big dad thing still i
still got a couple floating around i'm
sure i don't know what dvd's you got in
the collection what do you got ah
there was uh an anchorman
floating there's like something you know
when you move you're just like i just
take this box of stuff with me yeah yeah
girl's got a wild you got a girl's gone
wild i wish i had a girl's going wild um
never had the balls to pull the trigger
on that or a credit card same
i couldn't
[Laughter]
trying to beat the clock that's like the
hurt locker yeah
i got that big suit onto
cut the red wire
oh my god that's what you had to do back
in the day yeah you had that or blurry
porn on larry porn i would eat you know
[ __ ] music video gotta got me in the
mood i would go out so you kids don't
even know yeah you don't even know
no we i don't when was the first time
you saw a boob
the first porn you watched was on the
internet right yeah they've never seen
not porn porn
that's [ __ ] you know what i mean yeah
wow
that's nuts it was brutal
just walking around raging hard on
something you could swing from you had
to watch it with like four other guys in
a room and everybody casually excused
himself to the bathroom yeah you know
we would steal my my dad my friend's
dad's porn lust at sea never had to do
any of that never never see it was
called lust at sea i still try to find
it every now and then dudes just take a
walk down memory lane there's an al
pacino in there
i bet way more dads watch porn now
because it's accessible before you had
to have the [ __ ] tape with evidence
sure my dad got busted my dad ruined
like four laptops
because they didn't know what they were
doing and you always got to look the
other way
i don't know what happened like 15 years
ago
pop-ups keep coming out what are you
looking at hey facebook yeah
you're over there slapping it before
work we know what's going on yeah you've
never had to do any of that
no no i never had to work for it just
sit down turn the computer on and i
never had a group viewing experience
like i hear all these things come over
what are you doing later
get these tvs working here it's actually
pretty erotic i brought left to c with
me you're not missing out i'll tell you
that right now you remember that right
you're old enough that's the first time
i watched porn some friends showed it to
you that's how every kid saw porn for
the first time i assumed i didn't mind
it it was fine with me it was the
internet version i had a buddy come over
to my house and uh he goes yo i found
this website you gotta check it out and
my parents don't understand technology
at the time so they put the computer in
my room at like sure
holy [ __ ] it's like keys to the castle
my older friend comes over he's like two
or three years older than me he comes
over typing in older kids and he just
knows oh you have a foreign machine yeah
oh yeah you know how you know how we
felt when trump had the nuclear codes
that's how i would feel with you
and the [ __ ] just all the porn you
want to see at home
turn your key
yeah long story short he goes on puts on
foreign on the computer i go whoa i can
remember what website it was
hotbabes.com
right up the middle no guessing what
that is such a 10 year old porn site hot
babes
i want to see some hot babies where
would i go boobs.org my mom comes home
catches both of us and really there and
go uh and he just runs under my mom
she's got her arm in the doorway he runs
under it and we don't see him for two
weeks that's great hey i respected it he
was jerking off for two weeks
they must have
[Laughter]
see that's crazy to me dude i would
print out i would go to like free
ones.com was the big one where you could
like find that was like the first like
real database where you could like type
in a name there's just thousands of
names and we would print out we'd go
over like a buddy's house or whatever
and like print out pictures you would
have of just like boobs dude this is how
old we are like corey's secret magazine
wasn't too bad i saw a guy at the
library printing out porn old guys do
that a lot oh dude yeah you're just
crazy if you tell a kid that they'll be
like you went to the library that's the
craziest dance part yeah what are you
[ __ ] doing that yeah exactly there
was like for a long time there was a lot
of signs in public libraries of like no
porn allowed because old guys wouldn't
know and they would think nobody would
see them or could see their computer
screen yeah so there was like this there
was this wave of old dudes just watching
porn in
public i've also heard like porn just
like hid in the woods that was big yeah
that was the first porn i saw was a
magazine that someone found in the woods
it's an old porn tree talk about it like
it's medieval times yeah that's how it
felt like think about to a 25 year old
kid who's only had who's had boobs in
his phone for how long yeah they'd be
like porn in the woods that sounds it
sounds like michelle silverstein book
dr seuss the giving tree you're like
this is giving this it was at the end of
shawshank redemption remember he's like
go to the big oak tree and then you'll
find a rock that doesn't belong here
i'm there with a hard one you'll find
the cherry magazine
san juan
[Music]
yeah we used to stack them out and
me and my boys stole
tons of magazines from this magazine
shop stashed them all out in the woods
and then what always happened is one day
you would go and they would just be gone
somebody got them some greedy [ __ ] y'all
yeah somebody tuck them you can't share
the love jerking off to a magazine was
tough tough yeah looking back on it now
did everybody kids don't know how good
you have it i'm telling you well you're
also in public like i think jerking off
outside is the hard part i know you took
them home to the house yeah paige
did it in the woods yeah we're not
cavemen it was like a library
yeah it was like that take a book leave
a book thing
i like that people thought that we were
doing it out in the world i literally
thought it was like you go to the woods
get your book and jerk off in a leaf or
something we didn't have wood so i kind
of was with you to be honest with you i
get that jerking off like bear grylls
climb inside a moose
you got to recycle it yeah you gotta
drink i gotta use every part of it i'm
drinking my own urine and jerking off
oh man it's actually kind of hot what up
people you just watch a clip from our
weekly patreon episode you can support
the flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.com flagrant2
all right peace